good afternoon everybody so as far as
Python skill sets who is having trouble
spelling Python good who is new you know
six months eight months less than a year
kind of okay nice and who is over three
years you may find this a little
introductory get up and walk out it's
good some of the other presentations are
nice today
anybody here ten or fifteen years kind
of Python one since when I mean when did
you start using Python that's what I
mean when did you start using Python
twelve years ago okay so we're in the
same sort of neighborhood if I started
like fifteen years ago when it was a
little different than it is now
so what I want to oh this is just other
stuff that I did I'm I'm a writer and I
have books with packed and stuff like
that I also work here
enough of that so these are the five
kinds of Python functions and and many
of you will notice a problem with this
list so the problem is that yes there
really were six in there but one of them
is kind of trivial so I'm gonna combine
basic functions and higher-order
functions together when you get a book
on functional programming like Scala or
something like that
they get very excited about higher-order
functions they write them in all capital
letters higher order functions like what
is oh if you're a C programmer or worse
a Fortran programmer higher order
functions are serious serious thinking
brain damaging weirdness but in Python
it's really not very interesting so I'm
just gonna lump it together with some
other stuff because it's not I don't
think it's really all that remarkably
cool I mean yes they're different i I do
have to admit that but there aren't
really very much different and I can put
them together without a lot of trouble
so I just need to say this occasionally
I've done this a couple of times there's
an O'Reilly webcast and and you don't
know what anybody's background isn't an
O'Reilly webcast because you never you
never met them before so you know some
some basic math here and and my
canonical Python function absolute value
works with almost anything gives you
back an answer any doubts about that and
so one of the other functions that I
like a lot as a good example is this
function if mod I don't know if anybody
ever has seen this in in practical use
for a lot of the kinds of things that
that the data scientists do it's not
that popular they're like division and
averaging and sons and stuff like that
but div mod gives us back a pair of
values so the domain is a pair coming in
and the range is also a pair a tuple
technically and it's a very cool thing
because it sort of expands the thinking
of function it's not just like absolute
value of number two number no its pair
two pair oh wait so anything can be
input anything can be output yes yes
that's the idea that but nothing unusual
about it really other mathematical
truths just to to level the playing
field here that in general mathematical
functions are not supposed to have
hysteresis they don't have any memory of
what happened before this is just a
matter of definition sometimes they call
it item potency that it's supposed to do
the same thing every time and so when I
you know here's another function that I
evaluate the int function on this string
one Oh F 1 and 16 and I get back a
number 4 3 3 7 that always happens like
that no memory of previous events alters
the output of that thing every time you
do it it's the same this is a
mathematical thing that you don't have
to have to have in Python world there's
a way to work around it and we'll look
at what happens when you break the item
potency rule so the hysteresis issue is
a big deal for random number generators
the hysteresis rule absolutely has to be
broken every time you call the random
function you had best get a new num
and it best be different if you get the
same number every time it doesn't seem
very random however if it's a 64 or 48
bit random number generator there is two
the 48th chance that you do get the same
two numbers back-to-back I mean it's not
impossible it's just unlikely anything
that depends on the OS in Python is
implemented for the most part it's a
function in the OS module but these
actually depend on the state of your
system not on the arguments and so
there's this hidden input to the OS
function which is your computer as a
whole and so state change there will
cause functions to behave differently
every time you call them there's no
idempotency there's there is actually in
stir Reese's there so these are function
like things and if you want to be a
mathematical purist you can split that
hair I'm not going to split that hair
I'm done with the mathematical purity
and I want to talk about real practical
Python programming a way a dictionary an
ordinary mapping isn't that doesn't that
fit the definition of a function I have
a domain and I have a range yeah yeah
pretty much but seven kinds of Python
functions you know five f5 functions you
know that's kind of cool certain
consonants to it you know a little
little iteration seven kinds of Python
functions is like this is just getting
dumb how many different ways can you do
this well so far seven but it the name
doesn't sound very good so I wanted to
focus on the big five and we'll set the
little two aside okay basic function
definitions if you're new to Python the
death and the return any mystery about
this they're better now everybody says
you've know enough Python you can spell
it so you've seen this this is good and
here's my example
it's an odd little function and it has a
domain which is a number and I want to
emphasize the number like we're going to
come back to this quite a bit the range
it's boolean you know true/false it has
a triple quoted
string who puts triple quoted docstrings
in their functions on a daily basis I do
not see all of the hands raised so I'm
going to ask one more time
who is going to assiduously endeavor to
always put a triple quoted docstring in
every future function that they write
thank you I thank you my mother thanks
you my coworkers thank you your
coworkers thank you and the angry person
at 3:00 a.m. that is looking at your
model trying to figure out why it didn't
work they will thank you they won't
thank you directly but you know they'll
be happier because you have a docstring
and they're explaining what the heck
this is really supposed to do sometimes
your doc string can have duct test test
cases in it not the subject of this
presentation but doc test test cases in
your document strings are worth their
weight in gold oh my goodness
so not the subject to this maybe in the
on the Thursday Python code no Joe I'll
do some more stuff on doc tests but oh
boy oh boy oh boy it is a very important
Oh
so here is using a function and this
better be no mystery about this
hopefully if you're typing along this
also works for you the for people who
are used to Java and languages like that
C and C++ the Python functions are
really spare and some people get very
upset about this doesn't include any
type declarations you know what that
means that means bad things will happen
in the future there is no formal
declarations Python 3 5 allows type
hints you can provide some guidance to
another tool not Python a tool called my
PI that can verify the type hints and
that's a very cool thing only in Python
3 5 and up and a little hard
it used to at first because the type
inferencing rules are making logical
deductions about what your function
appears to be doing and you can write
really shoddy code that confuses the
type inferencing engine and if you have
written code so bad and so opaque that
mypie can't figure it out you maybe
ought to rethink what you're doing but
on the other hand if your stuff works
now you're in this argument with a tool
mode where I'm gonna change this until
the tool is happy with it and then it
doesn't work anymore so you know don't
go too far down that road with code that
isn't perfectly clean yet in a while
there will be better tutorials on type
hinting and in some cases you just need
to get a dozen more eyeballs to look at
it and between the seven of you you can
say oh if you changed it like this it
would be more clear my pipe type
inferencing would work and we'd all
understand it also code reviews very
helpful thing as helpful as my PI as
helpful as dark tests each object in
Python has all the type information
needed already bound to the object this
is not C++ and this is not Java where
the type information is ephemeral and
could get lost so unless well the type
verification you could ever want to do
is already part of the language what
that means is my odd function uses the
percent operator and that means any
Python object that implements the
percent operator will work with that
function and you say why would an object
weirdly implement the percent operator
that's like a normed only numbers do
that right no not only numbers do that
generally numbers are expected to
implement the percent operator and they
do it through these two special methods
but I could as a nutball create a class
that implements the mod and Armagh
methods and would behave rationally with
the odd function but it really should
not have happened like that that was
really a bad thing for me to have done I
should not casually overload this
operator to do bizarro things
especially in operating system related
things oh yeah the present operator yeah
use that it deletes a bunch of files in
your home directory you know that that
would be that would be rude man but
nothing wrong with it
generally all the subclasses of numbers
number implement this work with the odd
function that's what you expect to
happen the normal kind of relationship
among classes and functions so what's
important is a function is itself an
object it is fundamentally no different
than a piece of data it can be assigned
with an assignment statement that means
that a Python higher-order function is
dealing with a function or a piece of
data who cares I'm just doing a thing to
it I'm gonna apply an operator a percent
operator parenthesis to apply it like a
function maybe use the dot operator I
don't care hopefully the object to which
I am applying these operations will do
something rational not delete files but
compute something so I can do this
easily not even equals odd I did not
define a function not even with a def
statement I just took my odd function
which is already laying around and
assigned it to another variable I have
two variable names odd and not even that
refer to the same pile of code perfectly
legal you want to kind of go slow on
this cuz the alias problem halfway
through your program you're switching
from using odd to using not even ooh
now nobody likes you anymore because
they can't figure out what just happened
on the other hand you may have something
where I have a legacy function that was
somebody else's model I have a new
version and I want to be able to switch
between the two and I might have a thing
where I say the model in use now equals
and I can pick one of those two and go
forward with that one and so I'm not
lying about it I can just flexibly
assign a function to a different
variable to go forward in my calculation
with that new name
all right
this is where you want to start typing
code make yourself a shabby log function
it takes as an argument another function
and a value it can print out the
function and the value and it can then
apply the function to the given value as
the argument and so now I get stuff sort
of like this shabby log of the odd
function applied to three and I find out
it's this particular function odd with
its goofy memory address applied to
three and the answer is true this is a
lousy way to do logging but it shows how
a higher-order function the shabby log
can use another function as its argument
I can apply a function to a function
this I gotta tell you is the greatest
thing since they started putting beer in
cans let me just tell you the greatest
thing we'll look at ways to apply this
it yes wait I think sometimes if I
promise to weather like I'm altering the
image or whether I'm altering the
underlying function is referencing you
almost can never alter the underlying
functions being referenced so you're
talking about like decorators that go in
and tweak a function yes the way
decorators work is actually by creating
a whole new function that wraps the
original function because it's very
difficult to change the actual block of
code the code object that's attached to
a function I mean I'm not saying it's
completely impossible but it's not the
kind of thing that anybody normally does
so yeah your original function lives out
there unperturbed so what can happen is
if your decorator embeds a reference to
another function if I'm working in like
a Jupiter notebook and I change the
other function what happens to the
decorated version of that function and
the answer is I have no idea what
Jupiter notebooks does when you do that
kind of thing
when you're writing a big old script
function decorated version of the
function I would ever change the
function again no problem there but
Jupiter notebooks world but that's I
don't know if they really a thing if
they rebuild the function because they
know I mean they're watching me you know
the old notebooks environment it kind of
knows about some of the relationships
among things I would not trust it so if
I have a decorated function and I
changed the function that was being
decorated I would want to rebuild the
decorated version of it just to be
absolutely sure and you know so rerun
the whole thing from the beginning so
here is where I think the real coolness
begins this function map applies my
function odd to the individual arguments
in that list so the mapping odd against
the elements of the list means that
there's an implied for loop which I did
not write and that implied for loop then
applies that function to each one of the
arguments and I use the list function as
a whole to collect that output it make a
list object from the output who here's a
Python to sort of person a person one or
two the rest of your Python three people
my heart swells with joy oh my goodness
in Python 2 this is a little quirky in
Python 3 which is what I want to focus
on this behaves perfectly rationally and
it without quirks so this overall list
mapping odd to these things is just as
though we had kind of split out the odd
function and rewrote the map expression
to be a bunch of individual expressions
that were collected into a list and it
didn't involve me writing a for loop
it's very tidy succinct is the important
part about this very succinct so here's
my case study this is it's a diesel
engine alternator this is this is this
is as close as I get the actual date I'm
a pro
you know develop api's I'm not a data
scientist question the map function is
built-in map filter lists a bunch of the
ones I'm gonna show or all part of the
built-ins I'm gonna show a couple of
others that are not part of the
built-ins but map is straight-up
built-in don't import anything don't
define anything so in my friend mr.
Leeman here he doesn't look like much
but he's very important in my life mr.
Leeman the the basic engine turns that
alternator the alternator generates
pulses that drive the tachometer that
tells me what's going on down here an
engine world so it is an indirect
measurement of the RPMs of the engine
you figure that you know that it's there
tied together by a stupid belt how
indirect can this be Steve they're
pretty much the same thing aren't they
well they were the same thing until
somebody changed the wheels on the
alternator now they're not the same
thing and I don't know what the
relationship is anymore someone took out
the old big wheel which was about three
and a half inches but what do I know I'm
a software guy not a mechanical engineer
and they put in a smaller wheel which is
I tried to measure also but what do I
know I'm a soccer engineer I have no
clue how to actually accurately measure
the diameter of the full thing so I can
figure that if the old one was about
three and a half inches in diameter it
was about two and a half inches in
diameter then the rpm's went up by a
factor of 1.4 so what I see an attack is
a lie now and I believe it's a lie by
about that much and if I take the
inverse there then if I just multiply
everything multiply everything by about
0.7 mm I don't know the real RPMs that
the engines really have right so I can
write myself a little transformation
function
I have Python on my phone I really do so
I can then put in the RPMs that I see on
the tachometer and I can get out a new
one this is my model my model is divided
by one point that's a heck of a model
for a guy who's not a data scientist I'm
telling you this was rocket science for
me that was a model to respect didn't
have a lot of free variables you know
just rpms didn't have a lot of results
just rpms but still I was happy with it
very proud of it so then I get a
a device that measures the actual RPMs
and I discovered my model is completely
wrong so what we have to do now is we
have to actually run the engine at some
rpms and collect some data so I have
like numbers with data and I have linear
estimation models and I got my nel self
a new model this is the real deal of
course you can't do the math in my head
but so I can define my function Eng -
and I get out you know for 20 100 rpms
what it says on the tach which is the
wrong number it's about 1700 97.1 rpms
okay now I know this is helpful this is
really the RPMs on a boat will determine
your hull speed through the water and
they will also determine your fuel
consumption so I really need to know the
RPMs so I know am I going to make it the
full 64 hours or am I going to be adrift
off the coast of Florida I have a
separate optical device and I have to
hunker down in front of the engine in a
worshipful pose with the optical device
pointing the little laser thing and a
spinning disc that's attached to the
front flywheel and that reports the
actual RPMs that's a lovely thing but
it's not the kind of thing that you want
to run downstairs and check and then run
back upstairs to see what you hit while
you were checking so and you don't
really want to wish anybody else to go
into the engine room you know you tell
your crew members all right get down
there and stick your face in front of
the spinning wheels make sure you wear a
hat because long hair and spinning
engine parts you know their problems can
happen safety glasses are helpful and
hearing protection yes yeah oh this one
over underscore oh you like that
a Python it the read execute print loop
the greater greater greater thing that
I'm using in Python I don't know if the
notebooks do this but straight up Python
does this the output of every statement
is implicitly assigned to a variable
named underscore so when I did the first
calculation three and a half over to an
F I got one point four and that was also
assigned to a variable named underscore
so now I can do one over underscore
uses that previously assigned variable
so now that variable underscore has been
changed to the 0.71 it saves me some
typing the underscore has nothing and
you can't use this in your ordinary
programming this only works in the read
execute print loop because your ordinary
program have done that yeah that would
changes state all the time it's a it's a
peculiar little beast but it's an D for
this kind of thing where you're just
typing and and hacking away trying to
figure out what's going on so I have my
new model well see the problem is that
my new model is kind of dama because the
RPMs the number Wiggles you know give me
a break exact number of rpms that's
stupid and really it's only got a narrow
range of 800 to 2500 rpm so
realistically I want to do this a range
object from 800 to 2500 in steps of 200
so that's these values I want to apply
my RPM thing to just this short list of
eggs I can make a little card as opposed
to do a calculation for the application
of this model that's fine small note for
Python to people the range is a function
it makes a list object which can suck up
mountains of memory if you're casual and
don't use it wisely in Python 3 range
doesn't do anything we'll talk a little
bit more about laziness it's ready to
give you values but you must consume the
values from the range object using a
function like list if you just type in
range 10 in Python 3 it says yep it's
the range object yeah but what are the
values Oh list of the range object it
assembles a list of the range values
tuple of the range object it'll make a
tuple of a range values now we're
talking business this is where the
rubber is hitting the it's not a road
it's a boat this is where the wheat now
there's no good metaphor for so I've got
my engine to function my better model
I'm going to apply it to the values from
this range between a thousand and thirty
two hundred and steps of 200 because
that's the false reading of the
tachometer and I'm map one function to
the other and tada
these are the real are
PMS that are I need to understand based
on what the tachometer lives to me about
the transformed values using Eng - is
the transformation function and the
range object as the domain nice I like
this it's really hard to use because
those numbers are opaque let's do
something a little bit better with this
so I need a function to round things off
to the nearest whole hundred you know
the round function round - - is the
nearest whole 100 and chop them off to
integers so now take my range object
give it to a variable name tack so that
this thing doesn't get too long map and
G to detect gives me a rate a sequence
of numbers and iterable sequence of
numbers and then map next 100 to this
sequence of numbers I have this kind of
nested stepwise processing thing and I
get out
nice-looking rpm numbers that I can use
and no fuel consumption and distance and
things like that this is elegant
I've got function applied to result
function applied to function I kind of
like this it's not the most readable but
I like the way I have assembled up a
complex thing from simple parts correct
I have what I did was yes what is gonna
happen here is that this first map has
to be run because he's the argument to
the next map so this is applied to each
one of these values the result of this
map is an iterative sequence of values
it's not itself a list it's a lazy list
it will eventually create something so
then the next map is going to apply next
100 each other's values one at a time
give me a value can me better get up off
the couch you give me very would you
give me a value please how I'm gonna pay
to get up off the couch you can give me
another value and then you know then the
list is doing the same thing can I have
a value please can I have another value
oh please give me back are you done
giving me values and then when you
finally run out of values all right
here's your list object
but yes and and so I don't need to do
any more wrapping that and arrange
objects are kind of funny because every
time I use a range object it will always
give me values all other iterative
iterables don't behave like that
everybody else is once only then it's
given you its values it will never give
you another value but a range object
will just keep restarting it's an odd
thing about ranges what happens to that
final list there we go
this whole list of well since I was just
running this at the the greater than
greater than greater than prompt it
created the list object and printed it
because it didn't know anything else I
could assign it to a variable and do
more processing with it because now I've
got an in-memory tangible big old list
object full of numbers I can do anything
I want with that any other list
processing is perfectly legit so here's
that I already said this this is a step
by step apply Eng to to the range which
gives me an iterable sequence of values
apply next 100 to that and finally I
uses the list function to make a list
object out of the results so then I got
my numbers I got my other numbers I got
a problem here in that when I compare
this to actuals I still have one of
these rpm things is off by as much as
five hundred rpms and so at this point
my data science has exhausted my diesel
mechanic has exhausted so we're done
with that
I got nothing however it is difficult to
work with so here's another step of the
processing what I'm gonna do is use this
zip function to take the tech input
range and the engine output range and
zip will take one from each and make a
sequence of pairs showing me what the
text says and what the engines really
doing and now with this list of pairs I
can print that out make a little card I
can put in a spreadsheet and format it
up with a little bold and italic and
maybe red and green and stuff like that
print and glow-in-the-dark ink so I can
read it at night whoa whee and it's an
assembly
of individual pieces using map list and
zip as higher level functions zip also
is built-in works everywhere don't have
to import it this Oh zip does
interleaving zip a and B will interleave
items from each sequence to unintel Eve
I have to actually use something like
this a generator expression take the a
for a and B in some sequence and if some
sequence is a list of pairs each pair
will be assigned to a and B as it steps
through and I just want the a of the a
and B guy and this will give me a list
of the first of each one in a sequence
this actually is while contrived that
zip does one thing and you take it apart
with the other thing we often do this I
worked for some folks that had models
that involved a lot of rank ordering and
so a lot of things will end up being
sorted and based on their position in
the sort sequence some other ranking
function was applied and on and on and
on and down it went and so we were doing
a fair number of this creating some key
function that would be used for ranking
and then taking the item out without the
ranking number anymore and just applying
them in order down through and so we
have this this is a kind of a peculiarly
long thing but it can happen fairly
often it's some kinds of modeling
exercises yes the zip function there's
two versions of this thing the built in
zip is gonna stop at the short one and
the long one is truncated in the inner
tools library is one that will pad the
short one out to be the length of the
long one so you can use the inner tools
izip or the built in zip to get
whichever behavior makes you happiest
you get to provide that as a parameter
and the nun is the default
okay I've talked a little bit about
laziness the built-in functions like map
and filter are lazy
everything in the itertools library is
lazy they do not compute the results
until inescapably required so in these
examples of Alban using list to force
the thing to get up off the couch and
get a value do what you need to do and
when you have a cascaded series of lazy
functions I need you to get me a value
the next one says they need you to get
me a value and the third one says - the
last one I need you to get me a valium
one of them has to produce a value and
then it rolls back up through and I'm
finally happy here's a value that I give
the list what's really important about
lazy functions is how much memory was
involved in processing one value about
none I did not materialise giant
intermediate result data frames i lazily
got one value out of a source applied a
series of transformations to it put it
someplace else
this is the secret sauce to getting some
kinds of memory intensive models to work
pure laziness the lazier you are the
more likely you are to get the thing to
fit into memory lazy to the point of not
getting up off the couch until somebody
compels you to get an answer this is my
life's goal I'm not getting up off this
couch until I am compelled so what we
did here with this ridiculous example of
the diesel engine
we made a fairly complex mapping from
very very small pieces many but small
each one of which was barely a line of
code the kind of thing that you can test
in isolation if I had only put
docstrings with doc tests in them I
could have shown you the entire doc test
thing where it says yeah all your
functions are correct they all work and
so if each function is by itself good in
isolation then you have reason to
believe that the whole pipeline might
actually work and I like this a lot
because one big function with 50 hundred
lines of code in it
you know maybe somewhere in those five
thousand lines of code there's a problem
but if I've got 50 little functions each
one of which has got 10 or 15 lines of
code I can test those separately and
a lot more confident that the assembly
to composite assembly it's going to work
any other questions on basic functions
and this idea of higher-order functions
mapping lists and stuff filter good
question really really good question
give me about six minutes map and list
comprehension will eventually do the
same things so I can either use map to
apply function to some arguments or I
can use a generator expression really to
apply a function to some arguments the
generator expression is the slightly
more general thing because a list
comprehension is really applying the
list function to a generator expression
and you do it with square brackets kind
of implicitly but you could also do a
generator expression in parentheses and
put the list function out front of it
and it's the same thing as the square
brackets it's actually faster slightly
but yes it's very much the same thing
the difference is map can do one or two
extra feature e things that the basic
list comprehension doesn't do and
conversely because list comprehensions
can have an if statement to put optional
things in there it can do a few things
map doesn't do by itself so a list
comprehension is a map filter neither of
which is a reduction yeah there is a
reduced function it has been taken out
of the built-ins library and put into
func tools library reduce is easy to
abuse and apparently in like the Django
framework they had misused reduce to
take what had been an ordinary order n
algorithm that is typical for reductions
and somehow made it into an order N
squared algorithm because of the
function they were applying in the
reduction that it was doing a lot of
processing in the reduced function and
and it was a terrible terrible idea and
apparently metaphorical fist fights
broke out you know get
Zera tools knife fights where they were
just and so the benevolent dictator for
life guy - van Rossum said reduces
bandit is out of the library
no more reduce that'll stop you fools
from doing so then cooler heads
prevailed and so reduce was pushed off
into the funk tools library because it
is a potential risk area you have to
think twice about using it so you have
to import it in Python three five
that's the only thinking you really have
to do is to import it you don't really
have to think and some people still
don't they write dumb reduces anything
else yeah there is a trick for that the
first trick is to use type hints to make
sure that that it has to be a concrete
like list object not an iterable that is
done with a generator function there is
a way to detect if a Python object is a
materialized actual list or a generator
expression and what it has to do is
asking what is its itter if I ask for
the inter of a list I get the list if I
ask for the inter of a generator
expression I get some other thing that's
not the generator expression it's a
bizarre little assert statement that you
can put in there asking about the it is
the inner of this equal to the inner of
that and but it raises the assertion if
you have been given a generator in a
place where you really needed to have a
materialized concrete list object and
there was a presentation in PyCon 2015
exactly covering that exact use case and
so I'll have to look for that to find
that president brilliant presentation on
how iterative ility works under the hood
I'm gonna have to go look at it to make
sure I get it right afterwards I can
show you the code but I hate to type in
front of everybody and make a bunch of
mistakes so find me in the hall and and
we can talk a lot about that okay Oh
function rappers sorry I was looking at
sunset over the Atlantic Ocean function
rappers this is a small thing but a
profound thing what happens is when you
do length of some list which we'll do
all the time how many elements is in
there four thousand a million a billion
zero this is the actual implementation
for the length function it just uses
this internal double underscore what
they sometimes called Thunder method of
The Associated object doesn't actually
do anything so if the object implements
this the Len function will work on it if
the object doesn't implement this the
Len function returns a type error even
something like give MOT relies on the
fact that you have defined div mod or
perhaps are give mod inside an object
somewhere so the question is if there
already is a length method available on
the class why in the name of God do I
have a separate function for that that's
duplicative it's confusing it's
potentially evil because it's some it
hides the object orientation because now
I have called a function for something
that's really a method somebody's lying
to me I don't think so it's just syntax
so there's a few functions that happen
to stand in for object methods man it's
not worth a complete Stack Overflow
fight post after post after well I was
in on that but it's not really worth it
and this kind of thing does happen so
I've got some model that I defined as a
class it explicably and it has only the
one method that converts rpms and I can
define a function that takes the model
and the RPMs as an argument
why's the models rpm method to it and
the good thing that I get out of this is
my lowest use case here I have created
an instance of the model and then I've
applied this rpm function to that model
instance and an RPM number and it's not
a big win-win it's not brilliant
programming but there are some
circumstances under which this function
that's using a model object and an
argument might be clearer in the context
in which you're working that this is not
a bad thing it's not a great thing but
it's available so why not that functions
that rap methods it's perfectly legit
and if it makes things clearer pile-on
go crazy use it wisely because it can
clarify and that's basically what Len
does and a bunch of other functions in
Python they're just absolute value div
mod almost all the built-in functions
are just wrappers around object methods
syntactic sugar object methods look like
functions sometimes the object is
obvious the OS module is obvious access
to underlying OS features sometimes the
object is implicit so there is a random
Rand int function it's just a function
at the top of the random module secretly
it's relying on an instance of a random
class that you didn't know you needed
and you didn't want to know you need it
you just wanted random numbers that's
nice that's more syntactic sugar they
conceal an object creation from you and
we're all happy with that any other
questions on function wrappers are they
anything to it use it enjoy set a hand
like this function that is just totally
floating around for free right right
right yeah you could think of it as a
method of a module yes if it if it makes
you comfortable it's it is implicitly
bound to the module and it has available
module global objects to it so yes the
trick is that with classes you have
multiple instances with modules you only
ever have the single instance of the
module and in some cases the singleton
module instance is actually important in
the case of the OS module I don't want
to have multiple copies of that full
thing floating around it's all got all
kinds of bindings to OS level and buffer
things and trash that I don't want to
have multiple copies of same thing for
the random modules implicit random
object how many of those do I need and
in some cases if I have multiple random
number generators I have suspiciously
significant problems with those things I
want to have just one random number
generator that's going to generate all
two to the fifty-third random numbers
and so in some cases you want to know
that the module has guaranteed that it's
a singleton and so a free function that
is using a module level resource hidden
you only have one copy of that resource
in your app and that can be a valuable
thing sometimes
there we go no the function is its own
instance in a sense references right
yeah just about everything in Python is
done with references you know you've
made an instance because you have to do
with a class name decorating secretly
inside a decorator is actually making a
new function inside the implementation
of a decorator the function that
implements a decorator there will be
another def statement in there creating
the function that embeds the thing you
gave it and the result of that is the
defined do thing inside the decorator so
every time the decorator is evaluated
its building a function on the fly that
encapsulates the thing what got
decorated
lambdas because you asked about lambdas
so I decided to insert the lambdas thing
specially just no no it's a gift
this is Annapolis the lamp is tiny
little anonymous function no name no
statements it's just one expression you
give it some parameter names you give it
an expression nothing else and a few
things like my dumb engine model do boil
down to an anonymous thing it requires
no statements there's no if there's the
loop there's nothing I can write it as a
single expression and a mercifully short
expression in this case that it's just
you know a couple of multiplying power
functions and things like that so
lambdas are the tiniest possible
function definition a couple of things
that you're going to use them for one
thing is with the map i want to map my
engine model which takes an argument of
r and does some calculation i want to
map that against my tack object that's
kind of cool i don't have a separate def
for that goofy model i have the model
just buried right in the map expression
and when i'm done with it don't have to
copy it all over the place like the
problem is that if you get into a longer
a bunch of programming you don't want to
be copying and pasting that lambda
object around that is death as soon as
you want a second copy of the lambda
object you should have defined a
function but if you can ever find
anything more than a single use of it
why define a function seems to work like
this really really nicely the better use
case for this is things like sorting and
using it as a key for min and Max
because in many cases these key things
are actually used only once and so why
have a full-up def for a function that
you use exactly once embed it right in
the sort this is the lambda this is how
you compute the key from the object
saves a one use only def slight
optimization
you can also do this create a lambda
object and assign it to a variable so I
have a variable sum name which is a
callable thing it is exactly the same as
a function of one argument X so this is
the really shabby shabby way to define a
function because it is less lines of
code than a def it saves you nothing
runs the same as a def function no
performance advantage to it has some
disadvantages there is no dock string
and we have all promised that we will
write dock strings in every function
every time for the foreseeable future
right right lambda is a function that
has only a single expression as its body
in under the hood there implemented is
very much the same thing the lambda is
not a huge savings it's tell us to
create a code object and the code object
has to have variable definitions and
things like that very similar you can
tell the difference there there is a
difference in somewhere in one of the
attributes of the underlying code object
but it's not a material difference and
it certainly doesn't lead to any big
performance help the only reason for
lambdas is as I said with things like
sorting and min and Max where you're
only going to use it once because I want
to use the third element of this list as
the key you can't easily apply
decorators to lambdas but please if
you're off into that world to find
functions are very important to begin
with there are ways to apply decorators
to lambdas but let's not talk about them
let's pretend it can't be done any other
questions on lambdas I think they're
helpful I think they're underused
because it's confusing as to what they
are but the bottom line is they're
basically functions that have no body
other than an expression so use them
that way
callable objects the rules get changed
when you're working with callable
objects Vero Beach Florida
that is 75,000 pounds of boat hanging on
whatever's underneath
little floaty thing what is underneath
that little floaty thing I don't know
you want to dive down there and look for
it I don't think I want to this is
Florida they have alligators just gonna
hope so here I have imported this class
definition callable so that I can have a
class engine which is of type callable
and I'd have to define in order to make
a callable work I must define a method
named double underscore call if you fail
to define the method double underscore
call then any time you try to use the
class engine you get exceptions all over
the place as is appropriate you deserve
them and the call does some calculation
on an argument value we've seen this
calculation before it's a dumb model
it's not very accurate when we make an
instance of the callable class here I
made this instance Eng he is an instance
of engine that Eng thing is a function
and I can apply arguments to it
and whenever I mentioned the Eng thing
it's going to try to use the call method
by default if I want to define other
methods I can but generally with
callable objects we kind of limit
ourselves to using just the call method
so we define a class of callable we'd be
sure the class implements the call
method and we create an instance of this
class this instance is the callable
object which is very very similar to a
function but it has hysteresis a
callable object remembers everything
that ever happened so I've got a
internal attribute variable here
previous I made it a mapping if the
argument value n is in the previous
mapping well or if not in I'll do some
computation and return what's in
previous if it's not in L do the
computation if it's in I'll just return
the same previous answer
I am cashing my results not computing
them every single time this is pretty
cool and the internal compute method
actually does the real sweaty labor of
whatever the thing we're supposed to do
is actually is recursive it calls
himself recursively this computes
factorial recursively but once you have
computed any number factorial all those
intermediate results 5 factorial the 5 4
3 2 and 1 factorial are also sitting in
previous never going to be computed
again then we're never going to be
looked up they this technique is got the
formal name of what they call
memoization your spell checker will
correct that every time two memoization
know it's memo-ization i don't know why
it just is stop correcting it so I might
cache a previous values if it's not in
the cache computed if it's in the cache
return it and here's the recursive
compute method that does the real work
and he happens to call himself
recursively with other values and stuff
like that I call it a pretty standard
definition but please it's you know a
little bit of grease I think it's not
not really all that simple
but anyway it depends on memoization so
that it memo Rises the previous answers
it has hysteresis it knows what came
before it is actually a stateful object
and if you have stateful callable
objects you can optimize or you can
create confusion so you have to be
cautious how you use callable objects
that are remembering things that they
don't remember the wrong thing or they
don't remember something that baffles
other people they don't set up internal
state changes that make no sense we
generally expect idempotency if I call
five factorial every time I get 120
every time the first time it takes a
little while to compute the second time
it takes no time at all but I get the
same answer
the level of idempotency in the answer
but the performance changes a little be
cautious of that the other thing you'll
notice about this is that it seems kind
of boilerplate II if every callable
function just uses a previous and checks
to see if the answers the previous and
returns the answer for the previous why
do I have to write that every time
you're right from should say functions
import LRU cache spell checker changed
the func tools should say pump tools
make it say func tools but then I can
use the LRU cache decorator and any
function and that function will now have
cache values and if the argument set is
in the cache it doesn't compute the
answer just looks it up you should get
the same answer but the you won't get
the across-the-board performance
improvement because they don't share
cache so then you have to go get Amazon
Elastic cache and you have to write a
slightly more sophisticated function
that is aware of Amazon Elastic cache
and can go into the shared cache that
they all have to look up the answer and
so now your performance is going to be
limited partly by Network overhead check
in the cache but on the other hand it is
a distributed cache and once everybody's
all synced up things will run like
lightning because each process can share
with each other process through the
cache that that that is a a very clever
architecture and works out really really
well using distributed cache like that
people also use there's a bunch of
little databases that are used for that
kind of thing and I'm like Redis and
stuff I think are used to just put a
value out there that everybody else can
see and some of those use their own
internal distributed cache management so
that everybody can get at it so that's
why when we look at this the the
boilerplate for this
and say oh wait I have to define my
previous values as a one more time go
back one more as a mapping not
necessarily this might be a more
complicated thing like a reference to an
elastic cache instance am i never URL
and some other things in there but the
basic body of the callable function this
part is going to be real similar I'm
going to look up the cache shared cache
so you know the not in may become a more
complicated thing but the philosophy is
the same and then returning a value that
comes out of the cache may not be a
simple dictionary lookup but the
philosophy is the same that you would go
to the elastic cache if I have it here
it is if I don't have it I compute it
put it in the cache and return it so oh
yeah
the the design of that the architecture
is a little more complicated but the
idea and the implementation as a
callable object in Python yes that's the
way to do it
LRU cache is also in Python too and I
think it's in funk tools Mike it's been
around for a while I'd have to go look
it up to be absolutely sure but I think
it is because I any other questions on
the idea caching hysteresis memoization
those kinds of things higher order but
it's kind of a higher order function
callable object no they're completely
secret yeah yeah they're somewhere we'll
get the slides if we if I have to put
them out in the Python hub on pulse that
may be the other way to do it that is
one of the most wonderful questions ever
it's really good that a person like you
asks a question like that of a person
like me
you got a bench Markham and you got a
bench Markham unreal data because you
know your doc test test is not going to
tell you anything yeah you got it the
callable as a superclass implements an
error check that if you did not
implement the double underscore call
method it'll raise an exception if you
try to make an instance of the class
that is the only benefit of using the
call 'evil as a superclass as you get a
little bit of error checking that if you
somehow spelled underscore underscore
call underscore underscore incorrectly
you get exceptions no what you get an
exception to runtime when it doesn't
work right yes if you're gonna create a
callable class hierarchy though you can
wind up with a suspicious case that a
subclass is deferring to the parents
class which using callable as the root
will prevent because each individual
subclass has to define call also
anything else already moved on to the
next picture
Norfolk so here's a function it's not
really doesn't look like a model kind of
because given a value of an it I have a
divides by two or multiplies by three
and add so on what the heck but
interestingly it forms a little chain so
if I do the syracuse of 13 i get 40 the
syracuse of 40 I get 20 that eventually
get the one huh and then at one it loops
4 to 1 4 to 1 huh that's cool does that
work for every integer all right so
let's make a list of values for a given
number so I'll start with you know 13
it'll give me back the list this is sort
of the conventional way we do it we
create a sequence with like the first
number and then while we haven't gotten
the 1 yet we do the Syracuse
transformation and we append it to the
list and we return the list this is sort
of conventional ways to do things I
don't want to label this as wrong but I
really want to emphasize that it's wrong
it always creates a sequence it always
creates a big chunk of stuff in memory
and in this case with a Syracuse
function is a variable size but it's
still chunk of stuff in memory it's it's
real estate that you may not want to use
up all the time instead a generator
function a lazy generator function can
be used to do this instead then I can
apply lists to the generator function
and consume the values to create a list
object and it would look like this
here's my Syracuse iterator yield the
number while we haven't gotten to a 1
compute the number yield the next number
numbers are all going to be yielded this
is an iterative Bowl it does not simply
create a list I have to ask it I have to
do things like list of the Syracuse
iterator of 13 to have it make a list
object out of that sequence of values
because it's completely lazy it doesn't
tie up any memory unless I have actually
created a list or a tuple or something
else like that it's very efficient in
terms of can be very efficient in terms
of storage and so I would use it you
know for I in the Syracuse iterator of
three print it out I get my values comes
out to one like they all seem to
but I have to consume the results if I
just evaluate Syracuse either by itself
it says it's a generator function get up
off the couch and get me a value here's
a three give me back a number so I can
you know list of Syracuse iterator three
and there's the the values I can apply
it to five I can apply it to six by
thirteen interestingly when I get to
five I know the rest I don't really have
to wait till I get to one and in fact in
general any number that we see we know
what follows wait this is an opportunity
for memoization combined with a
generator function oh my god this is fun
just as a side note a couple of other
ways of defining the Syracuse function
as a little short expression in a def
maybe even as a lambda object we can
then compare these with Timon to see
which one is faster and we have and
here's the other part why don't I use a
higher order function for this and I can
so here's my recurse until I give it a
function that determines the ending and
I give it some function at a starting
value and while the ending function is
not true use the other function and
yield something this tiny little bit of
code is completely generic any ending
function any application function and
it'll iterate through it till it reaches
the ending condition oh I love this the
ending is just you know lambda a van and
is one for now and then the function I
can use one of the three versions of the
Syracuse function and I have a very
generic iterator recurse on till and is
one using the version two of the
Syracuse function starting with nine oh
that's right it's a generator object
it's lazy it won't return anything until
I go to consume it oh yeah that's right
okay so K list of hey there's that
underscore thing again the previous
expression that is to say list applied
to this recurse on tilt and and then I
get well there it is that's the the
sequence starting from nine ending at
one mmm I like this I have built up a
fairly sophisticated capability from
several tiny
pieces again I'm really happy with this
composition thing so the Collatz
conjecture is all point behind this
project Euler number 14 go to project
Euler comm you can look at this problem
the colex conjecture is that every
single integer eventually gets to one
but there's no way to prove this so far
but instead we can do interesting things
to say well what is the longest of these
cycles we start with nine it goes
through a lot of steps before it gets to
128 steps or 20 it since I guess 20
steps before it gets to one up to a
million whose the longest chain and
we'll the code seen so far this recurse
until will that really work up to a
million hint no you have to combine this
with memoization or it will not finish
in your lifetime generator functions
variety of things here but the generator
functions may be the most advanced part
yes there were so the when we call
recurse until giving it you know like
this lambda N equals 1 and the function
the first thing we do is we yield in 9
and then we start the while loop did we
end now 9 isn't 1 so we'll go on we'll
compute the syracuse function for 9 and
then we'll yield whatever we got then
we're back up to the top of the while
loop again saying well that wasn't one
so let's go get another one and so we'll
apply the function again and it yields
multiple yields is all legit because
every time the consumer asks for another
value we have a little handshake between
them the consumer says yield the next
thing you can have a function that's a
degenerate case where it says yield 1
yield to yield 3
I always thought it'd yell and like the
function will call them oh no oh no no
no no no okay
now we are you have you have guilted me
into live typing code at the last minute
we have seven minutes to go and I'm
going to break into live typing the most
dangerous thing there is def why three
of some value yeah you can't see it
because I did not drag it where even is
oh you're here that's where you are like
this right yield the value yield the
value times two did I take the I guess I
did that that yield the value plus nine
that's ridiculous right so if I try to
evaluate why three of some number oh
that would be bad wouldn't it probably
not defined in this context no and it
knows because the interpreters pretty
clever generator object it'll yield
stuff okay so let's take a list of the
things that it's ready to yield to apply
the list function to whatever that
sequence of values is and it says oh it
yielded a 40 and 80 and a 49 yes that is
correct so if I apply next to y3 of wood
used 40 again that will give me the the
next one of those unfortunately I didn't
save the object did I so I would have to
save this a is the y3 of 40 what's a
capital A oh no it's a - isn't it a
equals y 3
this is the one-finger special so now I
can since I've put it in an object then
he's the stateful object a because
iterators are stateful objects we get a
value from that and then the a object is
still malingering around on the couch
doing nothing get up off the couch get
me a value no that's a pace from
somewhere what the heck was that but so
there's the next value off the couch get
up off the couch give me another value
because you know there's more to yield
and it's a handshake between next the
iterator and the producer of these
things so each time they have to
handshake around the yield statement
there's the 49 hey got anything else huh
hey what else is in the refrigerator
tonight we'll just next of a what else
is in the refrigerator for me tonight
during movie stop iteration that's what
I wanted to have happen that's the way a
four loop works a four loop goes until
it raises stop iteration any iterator
does so I can have the yield statements
pretty much higgledy-piggledy in there
yielding all over the place and this is
an example of yield first and then do
some calculation to yield more it's not
a question of safety it's a question of
intent return returns a single value one
only no handshake no back and forth no
discussion no conversation yield gives a
value back but it's part of a
conversation if you want more I can give
you more each one is different
yield implies a sequence of values now
you can yield only one value which is
kind of goofy it's still implicitly a
sequence correct you don't know an index
that way you can however use the
enumerate function to a force and index
on them because the numerator will give
you back a pair now index value in case
but you can't recycle trivially a
function to say I'll go back three and
yield me those three again for that you
would need some kind of
stateful more-sophisticated iterator
iterator of some kind okay
profound stuff I'm glad you asked my
phone has lost its brain so we used a
multi-part iterator to provide this
recurse until give me the value I and
then give me all the other Syracuse
computations all yeah Siri nobody talk
to you you can put your head in a bucket
any other questions on on generator
functions before siri wakes up again
so and there are seven ways to define
things that look like functions and
we've got ordinary def functions you
know with return we've got the
higher-order functions map filter the
entire itertools library sophistication
beyond belief function wrappers for
methods of classes lambdas so that we
can have a function that has no real
body just an expression callable objects
which become stateful we can break the
idempotency rule think wisely about
using this also spell item potency
correctly generator functions which use
yield they now become an iterable
sequence they're not returning a single
value they're going to return values
every time you apply next to them and
then a mapping if it's a really tiny
domain you map it to its range of values
why compute anything if it's if it's
small and in many cases a domain of on
the order of a couple thousand values it
may be advantageous to pre compute all
the thousand values put them in the
dictionary object and don't recompute
them ever again
basically pre-caching the cache you seed
the cache with all the values they are
so d done with that then you can wrap
the whole thing and make it look like a
function
yeah decorators are absolutely
higher-order functions and I didn't
cover them because we wouldn't be done
by now it's all I got
yeah all those variables are yeah
function the variables that are local to
the function have to be to remove from
memory this is the law and so if you
want to have variables that are not
removed from memory they have to be
global you have to use the global
statement to make them global and
everybody will hate you because global
variables are their own nightmare so
what you have to do instead if you need
to preserve a large number of individual
values from a function you got to switch
over to a class definition and those
have to be instance variables of the
class but your class can have an init
that makes them like default values or
whatever a call that sets a bunch of
values and then once it's been called as
a function it now has attributes that
you can look at what looked like
property names you can use the instance
variables as if there were properties of
that object and it works out well for
you and those values are now bound to
that callable object they're not
floating around as global variables
anything else
it's a 55-pound rakhna in case you
needed to know thank you